Drive by day Joe Rogan
podcast by night all day.
Who are you mentioned because I
have a funny story with Anson.
No,
no,
don't worry about,
but I'm saying what happened.
He chose him.
Mauro challenged Enjo let's,
hey,
let's re let's boot rewind them.
Shall We?
Oh my God.
Oh,
Mr. Mark Coleman and uh,
Kevin Randleman.
We were in Boston hotel room.
Uh,
this is a after pride event.
We don't know which one.
And a pride back.
Dead and love to party.
Loved to experiment law.
You know,
and I'm a good humble,
uh,
innocent Canadian boy who hadn't
really gotten out much Joe.
And how it,
when we say experiment,
we're talking about with Mike [inaudible]
and similar to the bosses or more,
have you ever taken a Percocet?
I'm like,
what?
And he's like a,
have you ever taken a Percocet?
So I of course look at it up a painkiller.
Well,
how would I want to know
when I'm not hundred friends?
Come on,
you've got to try it.
He,
I said,
oh,
okay,
well why not?
So he gives me,
you gave me three percosets do not one,
three.
So I take these things,
okay,
fine.
Just whatever Coleman and
Randleman walk in and,
uh,
all of a sudden,
you know,
I'm,
I'm still,
I'm not feeling it.
An Egg.
You don't mean I'm very impatient.
I'm like,
well,
what the Hell is not working?
It's not working.
Ran,
humid,
asked,
buzzy goes,
what do you give them in Boscos
I gave him three Percocet.
You did.
And then all of a sudden almost on cue it,
it hits me and I end up,
uh,
incident any way was there
with us as well visiting.
And I ended up,
for some reason going into my old,
uh,
pro wrestling manager,
he'll mode and going
right up to ensign and go,
hey,
I think I can take you bro.
I think I can hear you and I'm doing this.
And I'm really just kind of needling him.
And he,
he,
he's,
you know,
trying to be nice.
He knows,
okay,
this is the English announcer,
cool,
whatever.
But I am pushing it because I'm,
I'm impacted by percosets bite.
But do you,
are you thinking that
you're doing a performance?
No,
that's,
that's the thing.
I felt like I was,
I was hot.
I was,
I was like,
Daddy,
your hand was out of my mind.
Thought you were going to,
wanted to beat up and saying,
I don't think I could beat him up.
Beat him up,
Joe.
But I challenged him to fight.
He finally had enough home face.
Paul me broke my glasses and I
got a bloody nose and I'm like,
well now I've got to
wear the badge of honor.
And I took the picture with him and a,
an incident.
I'm like,
yeah,
I don't think I'll be
doing percosets anymore.
I'll stick to a that the chassis ever.
Yes.
Thank you.
And uh,
never again thanks to the
Percocet is a good guy.
He has a really good guy,
Mario.
When he hit the ground he said,
okay,
this is over.
We're not going to,
do you remember when was anymore?
Randy couture?
Yes.
And He,
uh,
he was one of the first guys I ever saw
through a really hard kicks to the legs
from his guard.
And I remember watching that going,
oh look at this.
Cause he would prop himself
up and it's bad Karma,
whipped that leg into it.
And he had Randy with some,
a hard kicks back,
boy,
frank shamrock torments and a new way,
a lesson.
And then once that was resolved,
just the rampage when his brother
or what sentence brothers and Egan.
Egan warning
because of a what frank did.
And speaking of brawls,
hop out Coleman and de Maricio Shogun.
Who would,
uh,
who uh,
went to post,
broke his arm and shoot a saint.
Ambrose.
Phil Baru Federally Silva Stepping on.
Phil Baroni said pride was wild,
Bro.
It was amazing.
In a Honda.
You guys had like real street.
Oh,
the back.
Oh yeah.
Well then
walking into the place,
high and grace,
you decide out of the blue,
I have no cool white
to pull the fire alarm.
This is before the whole show stopped.
Site Tomah and buddy extinguisher fell
like a colored extinguished cognitive had
come and he's screaming.
Yeah,
everything falls out of the freaking
retardant and fire retarded.
He released it,
he released it.
And you have to show it
on anyway to show you.
I know he's just walking and suddenly he
separates himself from the group and he
hits them.
And you don't want to fight that night.
That night,
that the first time when he said,
well the [inaudible] was the first time
five members of the Gracie family had
ever competed on the same
card over Daniel by marriage.
Right.
So you had a yet Hanzo and Carlos would
at Hanzo highend Ho Dorrigo Daniel.
And who was the other one?
I'm missing disrespect,
but the Daniel thing is a weird one.
Yeah.
Is that your last name or
is it your wife's last name?
Yeah.
What in the fuck is going on here,
sir?
And went to a boxing gym.
Went that if I just could
use the boxing during,
you know,
to train.
And the guy comes to me and he says,
if you want,
I can teach you some groundwork.
She's,
you know,
I'm a great sheet.
I see your gray.
She,
yeah.
What?
It got married to a Gracie.
Oh,
how strange.
Uh,
but it,
but that night high and took
the mic after and went off.
I mean,
using every expletive I'm known demand,
just snapped it because of the issue.
Go Yoshito hoists,
Gracie controversy and well,
high end was the craziest of all,
but you know what?
We had some good times with him.
Oh,
real good times.
What I e a like you say a tortured soul,
but at the toss anyway,
always a good one of the few,
not few,
a lot of guys,
but he always went out
of his way to make me,
I mean,
you're a legend,
but to make the,
you know,
the main thing announced her feel good.
He always came up.
Laura,
hello.
Good to see you.
And well,
once you test
altercation,
we had old,
uh,
the bounces,
telus Randleman also.
And he did body the very first New Year's
Eve we spent in Japan for shockwave.
It was you,
uh,
Kevin Randleman highend Gracie.
Quentin went to the left to
give because he knew he is
sense of,
Oh man,
mad.
Hey,
you guys take him to the knife though.
The one that made the
most sense was this guy.
You were the one that kept
the peace because Kevin was,
was losing his mind.
And even high end Gracie kept saying,
moral,
don't worry,
we'll be okay.
And I'm like,
why?
He goes,
just trust me.
We're okay.
And I swear to God,
I thought he might've had a gun,
but what are you buddy
buddy buddy saying like,
well that's going on.
You would it be okay about,
okay.
So he bought some weed from
some of my bounces there and,
and,
and I didn't look,
because,
you know,
it's,
it's a felony there.
So I just get it and we walk
off and while we would walk off,
we realized that I pick it out.
I said,
oh,
that is not enough.
So I go back and I say,
guys,
that's not enough.
You need to give me more.
And he goes,
no,
that's not going happen.
And he has this attitude.
I say,
okay,
well let me do it different.
I'm going to be back in 10 minutes.
We are going to be back in 10 minutes.
And then,
uh,
at,
that'd be here.
So we walk around and we thought,
you know,
maybe we should light it up.
At least we relax and we're in this weird,
what is it though?
There's meal boxes.
Like it's,
it's a
complex.
And suddenly randomly start jumping up
and she started getting angry and he hit
a mailbox and then Ryan starts
and I'll try to keep these boats,
these guys down.
And I go,
no,
like you guys,
you actually,
I just got to shut up.
My friend.
I say to write.
And I go,
Oh,
don't do me like this was,
hey,
come on man.
Are you really doing this right now?
When we get this whole fight goes on?
I said,
no,
no.
We've got to elect,
stay with extra smoke a little weed.
We're going to go back.
Finally everybody calmed down.
We go back and these guys
probably call somebody,
but oh no,
no.
First of all,
these,
we'll quickly the guys,
two big guys and I walk over and say,
oh,
so,
um,
we,
we need to right now.
And they say,
oh,
we need to wait to,
because they're bringing it right now.
So right away already we are looking
back and sure enough there's two big guys
coming.
Also same clothes as they have and you
see them very sturdy walking up to us and
as soon as they see us they make a
one 80 and it talked back into phone,
goes from the guy and I go,
those are the guys calling you right
now telling you you got to give it up.
And he goes,
he opens the phone and into the guy,
he says okay.
And he puts it down and he
gave us a whole mountain
right over a movie.
Man.
It was hilarious.
But the whole altercation when everything,
everybody start jumping.
That's what Quinten left.
Yes.
This
various,
you have a great times.
Great Times.
Yeah.
Crazy Times.
There's a good time.
Yup.
How,
how much of a presence was the whole
Yakuza thing while you guys were there?
Like how,
how aware of you guys have
it where you guys know,
I know I was it,
but no one,
nobody would notice the occlusive.
His name is Hans and drugs.
They don't do anything like that.
But real estate to show you
saw people sitting down,
they'd okay you well,
people with like they were missing fingers
went
crazy.
That was where Masato the week boxer was.
Mickey Rourke was,
they're all 60 and we ran
this a strip club and uh,
this guy sits there and I'm with long
hair and he comes over to me and says,
hey,
how you doing?
Like a little feminine.
That really weird.
You've got to be the biggest
fan of biggest failures or
we've got this crazy guy
here,
right?
And I had no clue what to think.
And um,
he said,
oh,
you're a great fighter.
You want to know what I do?
And he takes his shirt off and he's all
tatted up and people start literally
leaving the place there.
And again,
I realize he's Jaga right?
So we started talking,
I was talking about it and then a
tattooed that I wanted them this color.
I said,
but in America it's hard to find.
At the time people only
wanted to use black ink.
And he says,
no,
that's not hard at all.
Why don't you come tomorrow morning?
And,
uh,
W I can do this for you.
So the next day he and I,
we go to this dodgy like five
stories under the ground.
Right.
It was the weirdest place.
We opened the door.
There is a cage would
have back that Masako
indicates with two dobermans
do fly up against the thing.
It's like just human skulls everywhere.
This pictures of books killing people.
Yeah.
This guy,
man,
he starts screaming and older people who
are getting to two at at that moment,
they all get up and they
run out to the displays.
They locked the door and I look at Mars,
I'm like,
Ooh,
you know,
because this is a really weird situation.
But no,
he was,
he did a great work,
you know,
but it was,
he started looking,
we made it big chairs.
I was taking pictures
of taking video of you.
I'm going to,
because I have a call with
a bullet hole in there.
I was going to actually
record an audio will as well.
Uh,
because there was a cage
where Masato used the term.
That's what I saw.
The kickbox.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I said,
yeah,
he would train in a cage in a basement.
Well,
five stories below me.
We kept going down.
It was the craziest thing.
If you think about all
the earthquakes they have.
Yeah.
You know,
you go like [inaudible]
with the Dobermans in there.
Yeah.
I don't know who this is.
Regular Trading Joe,
but that's a,
that's what the guy
said that it was Masato.
Okay.